oh my God oh my God oh my God this is
this is this is an issue how politics
gets crazy you get one side gets like a
small kernel half a kernel and they put
in the ground and they water it water oh
what was that try to get it to grow and
and so this gas stove thing you get some
bureaucrat saying something that has no
power and then suddenly you have Rhonda
Sanders so I'm going to protect your
guests everybody's going to talk about
gas stoves gas yeah you smug douche
Rhonda said this is going to protect our
gas stove Joe Scarborough is worth 25
million if you think for one second that
they are going to give up their gas
stove and they are going to give up
their cars or whatever else like you're
at NPC